and who the hell is the sky I'm gonna
need mr. Drake's property back oh are
you taking down
now let's bite all the heads off follow
up how's it going everyone it's been a
few days in a row now that we've gotten
some new footage for a venom and they've
all been really good and they've done a
really good job at giving us a different
perspective for each character this clip
is really awesome because it's the first
time that Eddie Brock really sees venom
and discovers what he can do so this
clip is really cool because it takes us
inside of Eddie's head we can hear what
venom is saying to Eddie in his head not
out loud it seems like there's going to
be a lot of comedy to this movie which
is good because there's also going to be
some pretty dark parts to the movie but
the comedy helps balance it out but not
too much because the comedy is still
kind of dark in itself so again still
sticking true to who venom really is so
again this scene is Eddie figuring out
what venom can do for the first time he
doesn't know how strong the symbiote is
so when he puts his arms up venom asked
what are you doing they then tase him
and venom takes over obviously in shock
seeing this for the first time he stares
at his hand wondering what exactly is
going on the cool thing that this scene
shows is you can clearly see that the
Venom symbiote and Eddie are two
different people in one body Eddie just
watches confused the whole entire time
while venom takes care of all the bad
guys venom acts on his own taking over
Eddie's body and he even saves Eddie at
one point in time by latching onto the
wall and pulling him away from gunshots
but by the end it's really cool because
you see the two of them start to work
together Eddie gets a villain in an arm
lock and venom turns Eddie's arm into a
giant fist he does not hit the villain
for him he simply gives him the giant
fist and then Eddie himself punches the
villain so this is kind of where the
Unison starts where they go from being
venom and Eddie to both of them just
being venom
and then of course you have to add the
venom humor at the end where venom wants
to bite everybody's heads off so that's
it for this movie clip I thought it gave
us some pretty good insight at the
relationship between Eddie Brock and
venom but what did you all think of it
let me know your thoughts in the
comments below
reminder about the giveaway if you would
like to enter for your chance to win a
copy of Avengers infinity war on blu-ray
a special edition poster and some
special memorabilia all you have to do
is subscribe to my channel like this
video and comment below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero
thank you all so much for watching Wolf
Wolf
[Music]